a
[Música]
y
en cataluña el gobierno autonómico
decretó el cierre de todos los bares y
restaurantes de la comunidad autónoma
durante al menos 15 días frente al
repunte de casos de 19 los profesionales
del sector están descontentos juzgan
esta medida extrema y manifestaban
frente al gobierno regional este fin de
semana calculan que podrían dejar de
ingresar hasta 780 millones de euros y
por ese motivo pues juzgan insuficiente
la ayuda de 40 millones de euros
aprobada por el gobierno catalán el
ejecutivo catalán dice que esta ayuda
podría ampliarse y confía en que el
gobierno central del gobierno español
también ayude al sector aplazando por
ejemplo el cobro de los impuestos pero
de momento no se ha hecho oficial y los
bares y restaurantes siguen descontentos
por esta medida
[Música]
bélgica vuelve a cerrar sus bares
restaurantes y cafeterías como en la
pasada primavera debido al gran aumento
del número de casos en las últimas
semanas también se aplicará un toque de
queda a partir de las 12 de la noche
hasta las 5 de la madrugada para evitar
sobre todo las fiestas privadas también
se prohíben de momento los mercados de
navidad y se restringirán al máximo el
contacto entre personas para el sector
de la hostelería esta nueva medida es un
auténtico jarro de agua fría porque
consideran que están siendo injustamente
estigmatizados de momento el gobierno
del país ya ha avisado que ofrecerá un
paquete de ayuda de 500 millones de
euros adicionales a los que ya se habían
otorgado hasta ahora para ayudar al
sector aún así algunos grupos de este
sector y han asegurado que llevarán la
medida ante los tribunales porque
consideran que esta medida puede acabar
definitivamente con muchos de los
negocios del país
[Música]
alemania ha visto un incremento
considerable en el número de casos de
coronavirus en los últimos días en
particular en las grandes ciudades y una
de las medidas para contrarrestar este
avance ha sido el de cerrar los bares y
los restaurantes a partir de las 11 de
la noche en las zonas consideradas de
alto riesgo pero esta medida sufrió un
golpe en la capital berlín cuando una
corte suspendió la medida en un caso que
involucró a 11 locales por considerar
que se trataba de una medida
desproporcionada en otras regiones del
país también se han cambiado o
suspendido decisiones que habían sido
tomadas con anterioridad para luchar
contra el coronavirus lo que ha generado
un popurrí de medidas a nivel nacional
un popurrí muy controversial pues hay
quienes consideran que genera confusión
en la población en general que las
personas no saben qué reglas aplican
cuándo y dónde y sobre todo que es un
popurrí que podría poner incluso en
riesgo algunos de los avances que ha
tenido alemania especialmente si se
considera con otros países de europa en
la lucha contra el coronavirus
[Música]